I give you the cutest thing to come from
Australia since the koala bear Olivia
newton-john
[Applause]
[Music]
nominees for Best Original Song I have
the tiger music and lyrics by jim
hedrick and frankie solving the third
from rock III music lyrics by Alan and
Marilyn Bergman best friends in life
music by John Murray's works by Alan
Alan Bergman fermius Giorgio it might be
you music by dead person
lyrics by Alan and Marilyn Bergman from
Tootsie up where we belong music by
genichi and Peppa simply we expel
Janie's the winners are jack me chief
[Applause]
accepting the original song award for up
where we belong Jeff Nietzsche Buffy
sainte-marie and will Jennings
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so many people are thanks Taylor
Hackford true gentleman
Joel silver putting it all together
happy go day will Jennings and the one
who makes it all worthwhile my way Thank
You Heidi alpha Stewart Naveen Joe
Cocker Jennifer Lawrence Kurtz oh ho my
mom my little boy Cody and most of all
my husband Jack nature you gave me the
chance to be a part of officer and
gentleman thank you very much
[Music]
all of the above members of the Academy
Taylor Hackford Joe and Jennifer Joel
Syl Stewart Levine Chuck a happy go down
mom and dad and Tyler Texas and my
lovely wife Kara thank you
[Music]